how was the medical profession similar
to independent filmmaking and how is it
different that's an interesting question
because i rarely do I get that question
usually the question would be you're in
the medical field why do you want to be
a filmmaker instead of a field in
general what's the differences and
similarities well aside from the obvious
differences in terms of training I mean
in the medical field obviously we have
to go through X number of years
depending on what kind of practice you
want and the more sub specialized or
specialized it is the more years of
training you have to put into it as
opposed to filmmaking you could get a
week-long seminar or a workshop and now
you're a filmmaker sometimes you just
stay at home and watch videos and now
you're a filmmaker right so which is
that's an obvious difference but then
it's it's funny and interesting because
there are similarities to it because the
training may be different and the
profession in itself may be different
but I think what this should is similar
is the concept of entrepreneurship
because as a doctor unless you are with
your tight in inside with a big you know
you're with a big Hospital and you're
one of their specialists it's like being
a filmmaker but you're tied with a big
studio right but if you're an
independent filmmaker or a doctor with
your own clinic you have to be entropy
or you know you have to be an
entrepreneur because when you're a
doctor and you have your own clinic and
you're not tied to a big medical
institution you have to set up shop how
do you get your patients how do you get
your clientele how do you do marketing
how do you reach out to your audience in
this concept your patients how do you do
that your dentist rarely with dentists
being a big big Hospital right usually
they are having their own cliques
chiropractors you know massage
therapists or any other therapists not
not to mention just the doctors
themselves but anybody in the healthcare
business they have to be having this
level of intrapreneurship and as opposed
to also independent filmmaker so I think
the glaring difference is really
training but once you're out there in
the world it's it's a it's the same ball
game right how do you get your patients
how do you get your audience how do you
get them to keep on coming to you as an
independent filmmaker what types of
projects do you have that would sustain
your audience to you a great example a
Kevin Smith you know you have at burns
people like them independent filmmakers
so to speak you know you may agree or
not but then they have the ability to
sustain that per project their fans who
would support them as a doctor as a
dentist as any health care provider you
have a level of service that you have a
constant clientele coming back for that
service so that's that's I think that's
that's a big similarity and how you
provide that service and or how you you
know introduce that project and what you
do in that service or project to sustain
and maintain that relationship with your
audience or your patient I think that's
actually the same that the level of
thinking that the level how you attack
that concept the product may be
different you know but that kind of
relationship that engagement with your
one-on-one with your audience or patient
isn't actually the same
you